d'accord les mythes d'obstacles et il se
trouve que le premier obstacle qui se
dresse face à lui quelle que soit la
situation
c'est nous-mêmes alors pas forcément en
cause une autre personnalité ou nos
capacités mais pour moi c'est surtout à
cause de deux manquent donc d'abord le
manque de confiance en soi et ensuite le
manquant d'autonomie et pour réduire ses
demandes qu'il ya sans doute des tas de
méthodes mois celle que je connais c'est
la pédagogie montessori qui traitent le
problème à la source c'est-à-dire dès
l'enfance
en fait elle est notamment impliqué dans
l'école où moi j'ai fait ma à la
maternelle et au primaire et où ma mère
enseigne en cm1 et cm2 c'est l'école
jeanne d'arc à roubaix et cette
pédagogie elle c'est celle là que je
vais vous présenter aujourd'hui parce
que pour moi il représente d'état
davantage alors il faut savoir que bien
qu'elle soit très peu répandu
aujourd'hui en france
elle en fait vu le jour il ya plus d'un
siècle en 1907
lorsque maria montessori première femme
médecin italienne a obtenu son diplôme
et elle est alors affecté à un hôpital
psychiatrique dans lequel elle doit
s'occuper d'adultes et d'enfants
considéré comme retardé et en fait à
travers un immense travail d'observation
et d'expérimentation
elle va parvenir à emmener ses enfants
considérés comme retardé au même niveau
scolaire que des enfants dits normaux et
après ça elle va ouvrir sa première
maison des enfants qui accueille donc
des ondes est fier des garçons de 3 à 6
ans et avec elle va construire sa
pédagogie
l'idée principale qu'elle va en dégager
c'est le maître et l'enfant en fait ce
qu'elle va remarquer tout de suite maria
montessori à travers cette observation
c'est que l'enfant est de nature
curieuse
en fait il a une tendance naturelle est
irrésistible au travail et en plus de ça
sa motivation et sa concentration ne
sont d'autant plus important si ses
alliés à sa propre volonté c'est à dire
qu'un enfant sera d'autant plus
productifs efficace et motivés si les
fêtes une activité qui l'a attirée dans
un premier temps et c'est pour ça que
nous nous devons de considérer l'enfant
comme le constructeur de sa propre
intelligence maria montessori considère
que le rythme est d'un caractère propre
à chacun au même titre que la forme du
corps et pour nous peut en changer sans
souffrance
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut respecter le
rythme de chaque enfant
et les résultats n'en seront que plus
concluants alors pour vous donner un
exemple tout simple vois dans ma famille
et mon nid donc trois enfants on est
tous passés par là même école et on a
tous appris à lire à des âges très
différents l'un en moyenne section
l'autre en grande section et dernier en
cp et aujourd'hui on est tous les trois
de très grands lecteurs
et sûrement pas ce que l'on a pu
apprendre à lire au moment où nous en
avions réellement
alors bien sûr vous me demanderez mais
que se passe-t-il quand un enfant
n'exprime jamais l envie d'apprendre à
lire par exemple belge est vrai parce
que j'ai dit plus tôt l'enfant une
réelle soif d'apprendre
il faut avoir confiance en cette strophe
d'ailleurs montessori pour maria
montessori pour soutenir ça elle va
parler de période sensible ces périodes
sensibles elles s'expriment chez tous
les enfants entre 3 et 6 ans et elles
vont concerner le langage la
coordination l'ordre les sens et la
sociabilité
elles sont relativement courtes et
passagère mais assez long pour que
l'enfant ait le temps d'apprendre ce
dont il a besoin
alors l'idée c'est d'avoir un
environnement qui sera capable de
respecter le rythme et les besoins de
chacun
maria montessori elle va donc imaginer
des classes qui vont présenter les
différentes activités à l'enfant et
celui ci il ira naturellement et
volontairement vers les activités qui
attirent son attention et son intérêt
donc en général une classe montessori ça
va présenter plein d'étagères à la
hauteur de l'enfant et ses étagères
elles vont deux suivants et disposer des
différentes séries de matériel donc ce
qu'on va considérer un matériel dans les
méthodes de montessori
ça va être des plateaux ou des boîtes
avec plusieurs petits objets qui vont
permettre de réaliser une activité en
fait maria montessori elle va beaucoup
miser sur la manipulation
parce qu'elle est convaincue et que la
main et lisse et est l'instrument de
l'esprit et que c'est de cette manière
que l'enfant apprendra le mieux donc les
activités elles sont on réfléchit de
façon à toujours apporter quelque chose
à l'enfant et ce de manière plus ou
moins évidentes ou par exemple de
manière évidente on va avoir des boîtes
présente un des lettres rugueuse qui
vont amener ensuite l'enfant vers
l'écriture ou la lecture et de manière
plus subtile
on va avoir des activités qui vont
impliquer des petits objets que l'enfant
il devra tenir donc à trois doigts et en
fait cette manipulation à trad à trois
doigts il va ensuite utilisé notamment
pour l'écriture plus tard et donc toutes
ces activités qui sont proposées par la
pédagogie montessori
c'est le résultat d'années d'études et
d'expérimentations fait à travers le
monde
donc on peut réellement dire que ce
qu'on va trouver dans les classements
des souris c'est ça c'est des activités
qui ont été choisis par les enfants et
tout ce qui est présente et réfléchie et
mesurer de manière à attirer leur
attention et à les aider à développer
leur concentration
donc avec tout ce matériel à disposition
donc comme je voulais deal enfin il aura
la liberté de choisir ce qu'il veut
faire
mais surtout il va avant la possibilité
de répéter autant de fois qu'il le
souhaite une activité ça va être très
bénéfique notamment aux enfants qui ont
besoin d'un peu plus de manipulations un
peu plus d'expérimentations et ben ils
auront la possibilité de le faire
et puis ensuite une fois que la leçon et
assimilés et apprises l'enfant il a la
possibilité de recommencer l'activité
pour avoir la satisfaction de savoir
faire et la satisfaction d'avoir fait un
progrès alors après bien entendu le but
c'est pas que l'enfant fasse ce qu'il
veut quand il veut une activité doit
toujours être constructif mais
d'ailleurs l'enfant il ne peut pas
utiliser un matériel tant qu'on ne lui a
pas présenté
donc classer au rôle de l'éducateur
c'est l'éducateur qui va lui montrer
comment manipuler le matériel
il va lui montrer et va lui faire faire
parce qu'en fait un enfant en général il
aura beaucoup plus de difficultés à se
concentrer sur les énoncés auront plutôt
que sur des énoncés pratique et donc à
travers cette leçon l'enfant va beaucoup
plus facilement le prendre et une fois
qu'il l'aura compris le but de
l'exercice
il va pouvoir leur faire autant de fois
qu'il en aura besoin et de plus il aura
pas besoin d'intervention extérieure
pour se corriger
va-t-il va pouvoir se corriger tout seul
soit parce que c'est c'est très simple
de voir si le bon où l'on soit parce
qu'il y aura un système d'autocorrection
appartenant au matériel et donc ça va
lui permettre de rester dans son rythme
tout seul sans avoir nécessairement
besoin d'une aide extérieure pour qui
risquerait donc de casser son rythme
d'apprentissage
alors après
les activités elles sont elles sont
beaucoup dans la manipulation et on va
aussi avoir beaucoup d'enfants des
classes montessori qui vont sembler très
passifs ils vont et puis d'un coup du
jour au lendemain ils vont commencer à
travailler et ils vont apprendre en fait
très vite
donc mon frère il était comme ça ils
avaient tendance à juste se balader dans
la classe beaucoup observé est en fait à
prendre en observant et ensuite
reproduire et l'enfant dans une classe
montessori le tout à fait la possibilité
de faire ça et d'observer les autres et
pour que ça se fasse bien sert
l'éducateur d'instaurer quelques règles
donc une qui est très simple c'est de
demander aux enfants qui donc se balade
dans le classique y observe de garder
les mains derrière le dos pour en fait
s'empêcher eux-mêmes de d'intervenir
dans l'activité d'un autre élève pour
que l'autre élève il puisse travailler
seul et bien sans intervention
extérieure est bien un autre phénomène
qu'on observe chez l'enfant en
maternelle notamment
c'est sa nature assez individualiste un
enfant jeune il n'a pas nécessairement
besoin d'être constamment avec les
copains il va en fait avoir envie
d'apprendre et d'expérimenter tout seul
et n'est pas forcément de travailler
avec d'autres et de la même manière il
ne va pas avoir besoin
il va réclamer dead sea n'en a pas
réellement besoin parce qu'en fait plus
plus la tâche est difficile
et plus ça va l'inciter à travailler
plus à assister sa curiosité et plus il
va redoubler d'efforts en fait pour
réaliser sa tâche
et puis de la même manière un enfant ne
va pas naturellement à les embellir un
autre si celui ci n'a pas réclamé tête
est vrai que celle inverse chez les
adultes
nous on a tendance à très vite vouloir
aider tout de suite surtout les enfants
et en fait faire ça sans que l'enfant
nous demandent de l'aide ça risque au
contraire de casser son rythme son
autonomie et sa confiance en lui et puis
en plus de ça de toute manière un enfant
ça n'a pas vraiment honte de ne pas
savoir ce que les grands savent pas ce
qu'ils savent bien en fait au fond d'eux
que ce sera leur tour plus tard et c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont contents déjà de se
balader dans la classe et d'observer les
autres mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
vont accepter de recevoir une leçon
un autre élève en fait les les classes
montessori en général ça avec des
classes à plusieurs niveaux
donc deux ou trois et ça va permet de
cette interaction deux plus jeunes avec
le plus âgé est donc en fait le plus
jeune là pour voir s'il veut apprendre à
utiliser un nouveau matériel va pouvoir
aller demander un plus âgé est alors la
vente à la salle des triples ou
premièrement même si l'enfant est
relativement individualiste
l'interaction sociale est très
importante et ne peut que profiter
deuxièmement l'enfant qui va donner la
leçon en fait ça va lui faire augmenter
sa confiance en lui parce que
l'éducateur lui a accordé cette
confiance lui a donné l'autorisation de
donner la leçon aux plus jeunes
et puis troisièmement ça va libérer du
temps pour l'éducateur parce que si on
regarde la pédagogie montessori comme ça
et qu'on se dit l'éducateur il va
constamment donné une leçon individuelle
à chaque élève dans sa classe à chaque
fois que l'élève va prendre une nouvelle
activité à utiliser un nouveau matériel
on se demande bien comment ça va marcher
dans une classe de 28 mais en fait les
dictateurs et peut se reposer sur les
plus grands curieux sur les voilà sur
les plus grands élèves et sur la méthode
d'autocorrection dont je vous ai parlé
un peu plus tôt
et du coup comme ça ça va de temps en
temps lui libérer du temps on s'en sort
il va revoir tous ces élèves qui seront
occupés à une tâche et lui va pouvoir
faire en fait le travail fondamental
d'un indicateur qui est le travail
d'observation et c'est pendant ces temps
là qui va pouvoir repérer des tas de
choses il va pouvoir voir en lançant ses
élèves comment les agences comment ils
travaillent donc la première chose qui
va pouvoir opérer c'est si un élève fait
un travail efficace et utile ou si au
contraire il est en train d'effectuer
une tâche à répétition par peur d'aller
vers la nouveauté là c'est le rôle de
l'éducateur de l'emmener doucement vers
de nouvelles activités qui lui
correspondent
de la même manière l'éducateur il va
voir si un élève utilise mal le matériel
sans comprendre le but sans respecter la
leçon donnée au départ là encore son
rôle ce n'est pas de casser l'enfant
dans son rythme et de lui faire
comprendre qu'il fait mal les choses
l'idée c'est de leur amener doucement
vers le chemin voulu pour que l'activité
qui est en train de
pratiquer soit réellement utile ensuite
il va aussi profiter de ce temps pour
repérer les envies de ses élèves
par exemple s'il voit qu'un enfant est
naturellement attirés par les activités
de lecture ou d'écriture et ben il va
lui présenter le matériel adapté
parce qu'en fait à ce moment là les
enfants ils sont en plein dans sa
période sensible et il faut en profiter
et puis finalement l'éducateur et va
faire attention à ce que les binômes de
travail qui ont été créés ils n'ont plus
faim qui ont pu être constitués ils sont
efficaces parce que notamment chez le
plus les plus grands en cm1 cm2 quand on
travaille avec mon copain on n'est pas
forcément très efficace moi je sais très
bien qu'il y avait des amis avec qui
valait mieux pas que je travaille
ou alors on allait pas avancé de la
journée alors c'est à l'éducateur de
s'assurer que les binômes je fonctionne
cocteau et donc au final le rôle de
l'éducateur c'est offrir de la liberté à
l'enfant pour que celui ci gagne en
autonomie et en confiance en lui mais on
ne peut entrer dans la liberté que s'ils
ont la maîtrise et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya tout cet ensemble de petites règles
c'est pour aider l'enfant à maîtriser
cette liberté alors maintenant je me
rends bien compte qu'avec toutes les
informations je vous ai donné là vous
devez avoir plein d'autres questions
et pour être honnête j'ai sans doute pas
toutes les réponses
parce que moi ayant vécu la méthode
montessori je me suis réellement
intéresser aux sujets que quand j'ai
compris que tout le monde n'avait pas
forcément expérimentés et que j'ai
essayé de te l'expliquer à mes amis
autour de moi alors pour faire sage doit
faire preuve d'abstraction et a essayé
de me mettre à votre place et c'est pas
forcément la mi-temps alors j'espère que
vous aurez envie d'en savoir plus sur
cette pédagogie
parce que moi je suis convaincu que
l'immense panel de possibilités qu'elles
présentent ne peut être que bénéfique
alors parlons-en renseignons tenons lui
la visibilité qu'elle mérite pour avoir
accès à toutes ces possibilités pour que
les enfants y aient accès merci